[Music]
my name is Jeff Hoffman I am the
director of the Massachusetts Space
Grant consortium Space Grant is a NASA
sponsored organization involving over
750 universities nationwide of which we
have a team here in Massachusetts who
are members together with the Museum of
Science and the Christa McAuliffe
Challenger Education Center Space Grant
is interested in aerospace education in
increasing the workforce of training
aerospace workers engineers especially
systems engineers it is also a presence
that NASA has in the many states which
don't actually have NASA centers and one
of the things which the Massachusetts
Space Grant has been doing really over
the last 20 years if you look at the
last page at the handout you'll see a
list of very distinguished lecturers who
have come here to talk about their work
in aerospace and this year it's our
great pleasure to welcome William
Kirsten Meyer who is the NASA associated
associate administrator for Space
Operations I'm not going to give you a
complete biography it's printed out on
the inside probably all of you have had
a chance to read it but I just want to
remind you first of all that with the
responsibility for space play operations
that means that Bill is responsible for
the operation of the space shuttle and
the international space
station so you can do the arithmetic
yourself of how many billion dollars a
year he's actually responsible for and
how many billion dollars worth of
accumulated hardware is responsible for
it is a very serious responsibility and
I think NASA and the country is really
very fortunate that in bill they have
found somebody who is not just a
competent more than a common an
excellent administrator but is also a
first-class engineer I actually first
got to know Bill way back in the early
nineteen eighties when he was a
propulsion engineer at the Johnson Space
Center and he admitted when we were
talking about that early today that's
that's still his deep love and he is
still working engineer and is very much
interested in the engineering aspects of
all these very complex systems that he's
responsible for in fact the the title of
the talk that we use as a working title
for a long time is the transition from
the space shuttle to the constellation
system and and and he'll have a few
words to say to that about that at the
end and and we'll certainly answer a lot
of questions about it but in fact one of
the critical aspects of the transition
from the space shuttle to the
constellation system is the continued
safe operation of the space shuttle
itself which is no easy task you're all
aware that the space show is
is extremely capable but it's very
complex it's getting old and over the
years we've had a lot of problems which
have had to be addressed and as a
example of the sort of continuing
engineering problem that has to be dealt
with in the safe operation of the
shuttle bill is going to talk about a
recent systems engineering problem which
had to be solved so I think this is this
is a really nice talk here at MIT that
you're gonna hear really about systems
engineering problem of operational
importance for the space show so with
that I'm gonna plug you in the bill and
invite you to come over for your talk
thank you all right so again thanks Jeff
and thanks to everybody that took time
to come here I I'll keep this kind of
informal and and I'll talk a little bit
about an engineering problem systems
engineering problem as Jeff talked about
and I'll answer any questions on
transition and other things but I think
it's it's good that you get a chance to
maybe hear kind of behind the scenes how
we solve problems with the space shuttle
and how we fly in space and what things
are there so I'll take this example this
is the flow control valve issue I
jokingly called this my senior design
project I'll start out with kind of a
chronological order of how this unfolded
and I won't do it in hindsight I'm going
to do it as it occurred to us in the
engineering community in the shuttle and
station programs on a day-to-day basis
so I could go to the end and then you
would get the Reader's Digest version
and we fixed the valves we flew them and
everything was ok but that's not the way
it really happens so now you get a
chance to see how it unfolded and then
you'll see a chance how we use system
engineering tools how we'll use the team
I will use expertise how I used folks in
in Mississippi people in Cleveland
people out in California all together as
a coherent team to go solve this problem
so so with that you got to get an
understanding of kind of where we are
overall and I'll answer any kind of
question
at the end that way here we go yeah cuz
here's there we go okay and that that's
the laser if you need it I mean the
middle one is is forward okay so this is
this is a schematic of the shuttle this
is that big orange tank you see out on
the outside of the shuttle in simplified
schematic it has an oxygen tank and a
big hydrogen tank the the system that we
had the problem in is in hydrogen system
and the way that the shuttle works is
that we have the three main engines and
each one of the main engines we tap off
the hydrogen that cooled the outer
jacket here if we tap that off and we
run it through a little thing called a
flow control valve and this valve this
tiny little valve controls all the
pressure and that goes into that tank
and it should have brought that I had
the valve with me in my briefcase but I
forgot it so we didn't bring the valve
but it's a little small valve about the
size of this of this device and there's
three of them in there and they control
all the pressurization of that tank and
so they're obviously a very critical
component so if you take a look at where
they live there's three of them they
live in the after compartment of the
space shuttle they're in these three
locations they're latch valve 56 58 and
57 they sit in those three locations in
the aft compartment of the shuttle so
they the main engines the plumbing goes
from there up to these valves then it
runs up the entire length of the tank
about 170 foot run of pipe goes back
down in and drops into the top of the
external tank and their purpose is to
keep the tank pressurized and at the
proper operating pressure so if you take
a look at them this is what they look
like in real life they're about this
size as the size of this pointer they're
they're made up of shims they sit oops
and this picture kind of shows a little
more detail of where they are let me say
go back they have shims on them I don't
think you're thinking else here there's
a solenoid that keeps them in place
they're here this is the way that the
flow comes down comes out of the main
engines goes in here
then flows through this little area then
flows out and then out that hundred 70
foot run to the tank you'll notice that
the entire poppet stroke is a hundred
and seventy thousandths of an inch so it
hardly moves it also never goes fully
closed it's always open at some point to
keep the tank there because if you think
about it the the pressuring hoops the
pressuring thats coming in is coming
from the main engines that pressurizes
the tank that is then feeding the same
main engines so it's a closed loop so
therefore it never actually has to ever
fully close and so when this cell
annoyed is is activated or energized it
pulls this valve in 170 thousandths
slows down that flow keeps the tank
pressurized and then when it's turned
off it goes to the high flow State so
with that you know everything about flow
control valves so you can check that off
on your resume somewhere now this is
what we saw in flight so what we saw in
flight was this is one valve operated
fine this is the outlet pressure looked
okay this is the the center valve latch
valve 57 it went essentially High Flow
and stayed at high flow until we got
managed and shut off this third valve it
shut down when this one went to High
Flow because they're all all three of
them T together and they flow into the
tank so in this one when this one failed
open this will in compensated by
dropping down everything was fine
absolutely no change performed exactly
the way it should totally nominal engine
performance everything looked good the
system did exactly what it should do we
look at this in-flight after the first
eight minutes we saw it right away we
assume uh-huh
the electrical system broke the solenoid
didn't work the valve went open we'll
fix the wires we'll go fly again the
next day no big deal and you will note
that that was November 15 2008 and again
not in hindsight this is as it occurred
so we looked at this no big deal
easy must be a loose connector loose
wire the valve didn't fully close so
life was okay now December 19th we go
into the
compartment we x-ray and did that xtal
that plumbing you saw there we stick a
couple x-ray plates underneath there we
put a radiation source on the outside we
shine the x-rays through there and we
get this picture now if you look at this
picture to the trained eye you can't
really tell what you're looking at but
instead of seeing a full round circle
here you can see there's like a piece
missing so so if you look over here on
this picture there's a full round like
quarter sized piece and there's this
chunk missing and what we see in the
x-ray is we saw this chunk missing so
that's what we gave us a clue as hey
there's something wrong here there's a
piece missing to this valve it looked
like it failed we pulled it out and this
is what we found so just a little tiny
piece and if I if I had it with me it's
really small it broke off and then that
allowed it essentially to mimic High
Flow and then the other valves shut down
so the failure was this little little
piece broke off and now our problem was
from December 19th is to figure out what
caused that little piece to break off so
first thing we did is we said we'll go
look upstream right see if there's
anything upstream that could have flowed
down into the valve so we looked
upstream and lo and behold there's this
big chunk of braze here right and if you
look here this is the outside of the
tube where it's braised in place there
was a hot spot when it got braised so
the the the person had braised it raised
it and overheated it it puts some
anomalous gold blob on the inside it
looked like a piece that separated off
of here we called that the separation
gap it looked like a piece of this had
broken off so our hypothesis on December
23rd four days later was that a piece of
this material broke off went down hit
the valve broke the valve and therefore
the piece came off so that was the
theory on December 23rd we'll find out
that this was a red herring and didn't
have anything to do with the problem but
it was an interesting an interesting
thought at the time so then we further
looked upstream and again what this is
is this is the flow control valve this
is the flow in then it goes here it hits
this 90-degree corner which is
essentially a block of metal then it
goes around and the
90-degree corner then all three of them
tee together in this manifold and then
they go up that 170 foot line up to the
external tank so when we took a
borescope when we went in there and we
looked and lo and behold here's two
little ding marks right where the
particle hit so it came in hit this
corner bounced off hit this corner here
and then went up here made no marks on
this area made no marks on any of this
tubing but yet down in this area it took
this little chunk of metal out down in
this area now the reason if this is
important was there's a concern that
first of all that this piece breaks off
can it over pressurize the tank that
would be one failure the other concern
was that it turns out that the flow out
of this piece and I'll show you some CFD
plots in a minute but the flow out of
here is about a thousand feet per second
so even though this particle weighs just
a couple grams it's just like a rifle
bullet going down this tube and it
didn't do much damage but could it
actually damage the tube here and that's
a question we're gonna have to answer
later could it then come up here damage
a tube could it ricochet here it's still
traveling 700 feet per second here at
this point it's 700 or so feet per
second even out here and then it's about
600 feet per second all the way up that
hundred and seventy foot line into the
tank so that that kind of velocity could
potentially penetrate this tubing so now
we've got to be careful if another one
of these breaks off could it then
rupture a piece of tubing and cause a
hydrogen leak which wouldn't be a
wouldn't be a good deal so then the next
thing we did is we started taking a look
at our valves to see if we could see
anything so we go to a scanning electron
microscope and and we take a look at our
valves and this is what we see on the
surface and when the shuttle was
designed we really didn't have the
capability to do scanning electron
microscope inspections like we do today
so we look at this and this is pretty
much that machine surface so if you look
at where that valve comes together you
know it's just like a like the quarter
pieces up here and then it comes
together in his little radius you know
where that little quarter piece sits so
this is a you know two thousand times
x-ray in that little radius so what
you're seeing here is
just basically the machining marks of
how that that little poppet is machined
around there so we didn't see anything
here that we thought was too anomalous
or too big a deal but you can tell that
there's a lot of machining marks in here
that could mask some things if you do
the typical kind of inspections that we
do and then this time all we used to do
is we would put dye on the material and
then we would shine a fluorescent scope
on there and we would look for cracks or
imperfections it's not a very
sophisticated technique but it's good to
find little cracks and little
imperfections and this was on this was
on January 14th when we when we did this
test so then we started looking at it
from a structural dynamic standpoint and
we started looking at the flow and and
as I described to you the flow across
here is about a thousand feet per second
it goes through a very small orifice and
it turns out that potentially that flow
can couple into this lip and this thing
can vibrate at a high cycle maybe a
hundred thousand Hertz and it could
actually break off so we had this theory
at this point that maybe the failure was
associated with this this extremely
resonant condition that could occur
occur periodically we'd not changed
these valves from the beginning of the
shuttle program back in 1981
so we intuitively you didn't think it
could be a problem but maybe there's
some coupling that can occur that this
thing can couple into that natural
frequency and just break off a piece and
would be essentially an uncontrolled
breakup as that occurs so this was the
first kind of analysis we had back on
January 21st it started making us get a
little bit concerned that maybe there's
something going on here more than we had
really thought so then we went back and
we looked at our failure history and our
failure history was kind of sorted we
didn't have many failures we had two
failures that occurred at acceptance
test program so these valves had not
flown anywhere they just went into the
test rig we were doing acceptance tests
to make sure that they were ready and
they failed and they the crack size was
oops the crack size was 57 degrees or
that little arc was a 57 degree arc and
in this case it was a 72 degree arc and
then the flare failure that we saw in
flight this was an 87 degree arc and it
had flown 11 times and then this one we
went back in our inventory and we
and we could see a crack and there was a
fairly large crack in here about two
hundred and seventy thousand so point
two seven almost a quarter of an inch
crack that was very visible even with
our dive penetrant activities we had we
had pulled this valve out for an anomaly
back on STS 97 we hadn't looked at the
valve we pulled it out now and looked at
it alone behold there was a crack there
so so we had this this data and this is
all the data we had and what we were
struggling with was were these initial
failures here with zero flights was that
this resin a thing that I just saw you I
showed you on the previous page or was
it something else going on with these
valves or were these outliers were these
manufacturing defects that we
essentially screened out with this
acceptance test procedure and we didn't
we didn't really know at this time so
what we're trying to do here is we're
trying to look back at past history and
relate to what we saw to see if we can
tease out what the failure the root
cause is or what the root cause of the
failure is so again now what we're
trying to do now is we're trying to date
of mine so is this it wasn't unique to
this valve engine position so we plot
the three engine positions we plot where
these valves have flown we're
essentially data mining to see if this
natural frequency shows up in only one
engine location does it show up in
others is it a function of the inlet
outlet diameters as a function of the
valve housing we're just looking at raw
data to try to understand if we can find
any correlations and we spent a ton of
time with this and we couldn't find
anything we then kind of kept looking a
little bit we pulled back to the
acceptance test procedure failures and
these occurred back in 1990 and if you
look at them a little bit in these
pictures you could see that there's a
nishan site and then they pretty much
just break in a in a high cycle fatigue
kind of thumbnail this is very much what
a crack looks like in a thumbnail
section this is the one over here this
is the one from flight and you can see
in it it evidences a couple different
zones that you see a zone 2 zone
excuse me a zone one is own two and in a
zone 3 and zone 3 is the actual failure
so when we look at this kind of it's
another view of the same thing you could
see the various thumbnails going this is
very this is very typical of a high
cycle fatigue so this isn't a one
kind of failure this doesn't occur
immediately this is telltale evidence
that it occurred over a large number of
cycles so this appears to us to be some
kind of high cycle fatigue issue but not
an immediate failure but our ATP cases
those all clearly look like they just
immediately failed on the first
application of load so you put load on
it and it failed so we used this data to
kind of say that well maybe these are
just outliers we'll throw that data out
we've got some kind of high cycle
fatigue problem we're probably okay to
fly as long as we screened for cracks
it's kind of what we thought at this
time now I will tell you that is what I
thought I have a large team that
supports me and part of my team has
carries the title safety so they have to
think the opposite way I do no matter
what I say and and they're thinking it
doesn't matter this is just nice
pictures you're crazy it's the same
failure it can happen any time we're
grounded in a fleet right so then we're
having wonderful discussions about all
this but that's life and that's that's
actually good so then we said okay now
if they're going to tell me it can
happen on any flight
I'll go look at the consequence side so
what I did now is I went down to two
with a team went down to New Orleans
down to the Stennis Space Flight Center
and we essentially mocked up the 79 foot
a tubing so we actually put 79 feet of
tubing exactly the same size there we
put an orifice in the line we put a
couple cam reports in we put some laser
measurement ports in so we can get the
velocity right and we build a little
system to drop particles into this
system and we were firing particles at
700 feet per second down this tube and
so we fired about 200 or 300 particles
down this tube and you can see here this
is what it looked like in the worst Bend
which was this first this first elbow
here just little scuff marks no big no
big dings no big hardware and you can
see here if you look really hard we
actually bowed the medal out a little
bit with one of the shots so it's a kind
of a probabilistic game of if they fly
exactly the right way and they hit flat
edge on they're just going to scrape but
if they go knife edge on they can really
cause some damage so even though this is
pretty compelling test data
it still wasn't good enough necessarily
for my analyst so then at this time we
said okay can we do a better job of
inspecting so what you see up here is is
week whoops well what you see up here is
we figured out a way to take that little
edge where that little medal is and we
actually polish it with diamond dust so
where you saw all those little machine
marks before if we put diamond dust on a
little small piece of cloth and we put a
toothpick on there we can actually shine
that piece up such then when we do the
scanning electron microscope it's not
hidden by the machining marks and we can
look for cracks so this was a brand new
technique that we kind of developed on
the fly to go do this diamond polishing
to not destroy it now the other problem
I had was I couldn't remove a
significant amount of metal here or I
would invalidate my flight hardware
because the shuttle program is ending I
took away the the flow balancing rig
that allows me to set the the solenoid
strength with the flow through the valve
to the proper proper current so it moves
in the right direction so I didn't have
a way once I removed metal from these to
ever fly these valves again so once I
once I actually even did this little bit
of polishing the valve was no longer
certified for flight so I couldn't go
look at all my flight valves with this
technique or I would invalidate it and
wouldn't it be a piece of flight
hardware now I can I'm in the process
now and the flow rig is up now and it's
available today but we would have missed
that launch window we would have been
after the Soyuz we would probably be
trying to launch about this time now
with the shuttle mission if we would
have destroyed our flight assets so I'm
so I'm now constrained so this is a this
is a different problem than you'd like
to have as an engineer I I would like to
go take my best inspection technique and
use it but I can't because if I use that
best inspection technique I've lost the
ability to go fly that piece of hardware
so that's another consideration that we
face in the engineering world that
sometimes you don't face in the outside
world so then we took a look at our
older valves which we which we could
easily do these are the the excuse me
these are the newer valves and because I
didn't have the new inspection technique
I'm looking at these with dye penetrant
and I'm seeing no cracks there's no
cracks in any of my new valves that I'm
flying the only crack i there
had was this one that actually broke
unflyable drache now maybe there's
something between my old valves and my
new valves that are there but I'm really
blinded here because I have a very bad
inspection technique I just had this dye
pen inspection technique I don't have a
way to really look for the very very
small cracks and so then then what we're
doing here is that now we can actually
start to see some of these cracks and
these in these older valves and this
gives you a feel for how small we're
looking for you know the big black line
up here is two thousandths of an inch
this crack width down here is about a
thousandth of an inch and these are
really small and so if you think about
it I do this diamond dust on the lathe I
polish it up and then I take four
thousand images around the top of the
valve and then I have someone manually
inspect all four thousand of those
images looking for cracks on the order
of a thousandth of an inch to two maybe
ten thousandths of an inch in length and
so at first I go to my guys why is it
taking you like two days to inspect my
valves you should be able to get these
pictures and get him back and then they
showed me the four thousand images and
they asked me if I would like to go
through those four thousand images in
the next half hour and give them an
answer and I said okay I understand
so then we we went back again and this
is what we saw with this technique in
the older valves we saw lots of cracks I
mean they were everywhere now the other
thing that's important is these valves
have flown since the first shuttle
flight so there has been no change from
the first shuttle flight so we are
flying with this same risk whether we
realized it or not since sts-1 back in
1981 until today and because we didn't
have a good inspection technique we
thought everything was okay but in
reality here's what we were flying with
and we didn't and this is the one that
we found later this is a big cracked you
know quarter of an inch long we even saw
that with the dye pen the other ones we
couldn't see but but we had a
significant amount of cracks in our
valves which means potentially we could
be losing a lot of these if they couple
into this this flow so there's there's
definitely something on here we need to
be looking at this is a serious problem
we got to really understand
before we can go back flying so again
this is this is again this is before
polishing right so you can see all the
machine marks here then down here you
can see it after polishing and then you
can see this is what it the crack looks
like and then I blew it up over here so
the again you can see the crack over
here on this side so so this is a very
good technique this really gives us a
great way to go look at these outs the
problem is that it invalidates the valve
as a flight valve so this is the
technique I really want to use but I
can't use so again just another picture
of the crack again now we're now we're
again back looking at its some of these
so when we found these cracks we've now
got the ability to now load the edge of
the valve so now I put it in an
instrument which you guys are familiar
with and I thought and I tack on a
little strut on the end and now I'm
going to pull on the valve until it
fails and so what I'm doing is I'm
pulling on the valve with 250 pounds
12,000 cycles and I get a failure like
this I pull on the valve 175 pounds for
3,000 cycles I get failures like this
and and so what I'm doing here is I'm
trying to understand is this high cycle
fatigue where we get the three zones of
fracture is that real and you can start
to see in these pictures it shows that
the various failures zones just like we
saw before so this looks like a very
promising failure mode so this I'm going
to try to use with my engineering team
to say I'm ready to go fly when I'm
going to try to tell them is if I die
pinned I didn't see any cracks I didn't
have I've you know I've got maybe twelve
flights on these files nowhere near
these number of cycles I'm a long way
away from a failure that's good enough
to go fly let's go fly so this is the
rationale I'm about ready to go try with
my team and you'll see at the end a
timeline of where I failed with this
rationale but at least I tried so again
this is just this the same same thing
you can see this is the part that
actually failed two three zones we
talked about the four zones and then
down here I did another overload and
here what I did is I to get it to fail I
notched a little
P so I notched the two corners and then
I loaded it and then I and I overloaded
it and it popped and why this is
important is the crack ran and it would
I ran further except I ran into the
notch that we put in to make it fail so
the problem here was I had to also limit
the size of the failure because if I
lost a big enough piece the particle
testing where I was shooting particles
down the tubes showed that I could
penetrate a piece of tube and caused a
hydrogen leak which we thought at the
time was a big deal so so I was again
trapped and I had to bound the size I
had to show that enough life in these
parts with die pin and I could go fly
and that's the rough flight rash now we
were trying to get together and then
then my wonderful dynamicists
CFD guys came along and they did this
plot and what they found here was it is
the engines throttle up and down the
valve position moves a little bit and it
turns out that depending on where we are
in the throttling case you can either
and the material you can either couple
into one of these dynamic modes or not
couple into this dynamic mode so going
back to the original theory where I
showed you that you could get the single
event that fails there now giving me a
postulation of why it doesn't occur very
often it only occurs when I'm in certain
throttling conditions and I have to stay
in that throttling condition long enough
for it to fail so then we went and we
said well k will try to fire some bigger
particles so we fired him into that
elbow and you can see right here I shot
a hole through the elbow which wasn't
such a good thing
I actually got so good at sending these
things down I could actually get him to
stick in the elbow which which was not a
good thing but my test team was
exceptionally proud of this they
calculated ahead of time what velocity
they needed to get it to stick into the
elbow and then they bet me five dollars
that it would stick in the elbow and
it's stuck in the elbow and I paid him
five dollars but I didn't feel so good
about that but so we so we had good
analysis but it's it showed that hey
this is a this is really a potential
problem and and you can see the same
thing here we also put holes and this is
what the elbow looks like in itself we
manufactured a bunch of these and when
in Cleveland we actually just shot these
particles at him to see what would
happen so then then finally this is kind
of kind of coming to the end is that
then what happened was we we had these
assets and then luckily
team kept working on another another
inspection technique and I'll show you
some pictures of a minute it's it's
eddy-current and they were able to use
eddy current to define cracks so these
are my old valves these the ones where
we saw the cracks before we had
previously not seen any cracks here but
now I can get eddy current indications
that show that there are cracks even in
my flight valves so I got a new
inspection technique that allowed me to
now determine that there were very small
cracks present in some of these valves
so now I had a method to go can't a
hand-select valve to show that there
were no cracks with any detectable
method of inspection and that's
eventually how we got to go to flight
again this just shows the various NDE
techniques polishing and etching mag
particle eddy current and then scanning
electron microscope you know they're
kind of all different techniques but
probably the scanning electron
microscope is the definitive one if you
can look at the images eddy current
turned out to be very very good and I'll
show you a picture of that in a minute
but again I didn't have that technique
until the very end until the till the
large kind of time frame just before
flight and what happened was I didn't
even know that this existed I was about
ready to throw in the towel I told my
team we're not going to fly unless we
can inspect so therefore we're gonna
have to fix the flow balancing rig we're
going to stand down we're not gonna fly
for a couple months and they go well we
got this new technique we've been
working on we haven't told you about it
it's called eddy current we'd like to
try it on these valves if we can and it
works would you accept that as flight
rationale and I said well ok so then
they went ahead and did that and what
they did is they went out and they
bought a bolt tester and they had done
this at Christmas so maybe this is a
Christmas gift they bought this bolt
tester and it has a very nice little
probe on it that it fits right this is
the poppet it fits right into the area
of a problem and then the valve scans
around and in about 20 minutes they get
a trace of the entire interface and it
it looks for imperfections in there by
looking at the eddy current changes and
it can detect get tech the failures and
it turned out to be very reliable and
and this isn't this is an actual chart a
picture of the screen sample of the
picture and and even I can find the
cracks there here and then they repeat
down here again because they actually
rotate the part around twice to confirm
them but this is very
it doesn't does no damage to the part
and it's a hundred percent it's actually
better in some ways in the scanning
electron microscope because it doesn't
need the human to go find it
so with this tool I had the way to go
select valves and this was this was the
way we ultimately ended up going to fly
it at the same time we nice when I
punched a hole in the corner right we
never give up at NASA right so we had
designed this and this is a doubler
right so we built this little device
that we could install in the orbiter out
at the pad and actually go fly with it
carries a little o-ring in here so when
you punched a hole in the corner it
seals itself and will not leak so I had
these built their certified they're
ready to go fly we chose not to fly them
but they're available if we want to go
fly them so so if you can't fix the
problem itself can you then put some
kind of splint or bandaid on the outside
it makes the consequences less for you
and that was the intent of this device
but we ended up not having to use that
so then basically where we ended up with
what we thinks going on is we thinks
going on is hydrogen assisted high cycle
fatigue so the fact that it's in a
hydrogen environment it's in briteling
that interface so when a small crack
starts it hardens in that interface at
then cycles and then hardens a little
more in cycles and hardens a little more
and then finally relieves itself so
we're pretty confident if we can fly
valves without cracks we have a good
flight rationale and that's going to be
our rationale for probably the remaining
number of flights on the shuttle we do
PR a so you know we looked at the
probability of the the poppet braking
the probability of the size being big
enough to cause damage the probability
of an impact and the probability of
actually causing some kind of damage and
then this is loss of crew and vehicle so
we're looking at probably with a wear
out case that we think we have about a 1
in 450 risk of flying with this design
so again this is and I won't go through
this but this is basically the
chronology of what I just talked to you
about but but what you see through here
is you know hoops again I tried to get
the flight ration out here we do a big
Flight Readiness review there was no way
I was going to get the resolution here
we waited until the next chart we waited
till
here on February 20th I thought I had
good enough rationale there that didn't
work and then we finally got
eddy-current here and then that was the
thing that actually allowed us to go fly
down here on at least attempt to fly on
March 11th and then we ended up
scrubbing on that flight for an
unrelated hydrogen leaf but but the
thing you ought to take out of this in
terms of message is you didn't hear
about any of this in the press all you
hear about in the press is the shuttle
didn't fly some aging hardware problem
right and it was an aging hardware
problem it was a design problem the
design problem was there from the
beginning of the program we were exposed
to the same risk all along we had seen
this a couple times and other failures
but we didn't pursue it to this level
and now that we finally pursued it to
this level I think we understand this
problem and and we know where we are now
the story that's not up here is we flew
successfully we got back we had
occurring into valves they were fine
they were crack free I then got my flow
balancing facility up I put one of the
valves in a flow balancing facility and
after the flow balancing facility a
crack showed up so this implies to me
that there's still this loading
phenomenon going on the flow balancing
facility uses nitrogen it uses higher
pressures and higher flow rates so they
can definitely stress these valves so
we're still gonna use the same rationale
to scan no crack free and in go fly
we're also looking at an alternate
material to go change so hopefully
through all this you know you kind of
got an idea of of what it takes to
actually get a shuttle launch and and
and what our what my life is as a
program manager or AAA it's at
headquarters now as a a I'm not supposed
to do any of this stuff as Jeff said I'm
not supposed to understand anything
technically I'm supposed to be a
politician that goes and talks to all
the White House staffers and the
executive office of the president and
all those folks but in my passion my
passion is this stuff they momentarily
got me stuck in DC so so rather than
talking about shuttle phase-out
transition and politics and those kind
of things I'd rather talk about
engineering so so hopefully out all this
you learn something about how we do
systems engineering this is a huge
effort the team is probably about a
thousand people supporting this there
in Cleveland there in Louisiana they
were in California they were in Marshall
Space Flight Center I've got fluid
dynamics guys I got materials guys I got
indie guys working on this and gals I
mean it's it's an amazing team of
pulling all this effort together to go
essentially from this problem we saw
really in December until flight in March
which is a pretty phenomenal amount of
work in three months you know I've
probably fired over maybe a thousand
particles at tubes I probably I ran
computer Cray runs on the order of
probably a couple hours out at Ames look
at it at the cfd stuff so the amount of
effort and work that went into this is
phenomenal the amount of weekend's the
amount of holiday time that the teams
put in is just unbelievable so you don't
see any of that but then when this flies
I can tell you I was not looking out the
window in Florida at the shuttle launch
I was looking at the data of the flow
control valves and watching those
pressures at the outlets to see how the
fouls were doing and I didn't really
care about looking out the window I knew
what I needed to go look at in terms of
data so again that that engineer
tendency comes through
so with that I'll kind of conclude and
open it up to any kind of questions you
have anything you want to talk about
just feel free to ask and and I'll talk
to you about any subject of that you'd
like so thanks
[Applause]
yep we sure it turns out we looked at
the oxygen valve see I didn't show you
but there's a very similar system on the
oxygen side that pressurizes the oxygen
system we also tapped the oxygen off and
feed it in the oxygen tank we're doing
exactly the same thing with those valves
and and the technique works really well
so this bolt tester was actually
designed by by a company I think in the
oil field industry to look at bolts to
look at bolt heads so this tool is
designed very nice has two little tiny
probes that sit right on the edge it
makes it just perfect for doing this
task for this design so that's another
huge lesson learned is you don't need to
go out and invent your new technique or
your new concept see what other folks
are doing in a totally different
industry and can you then adapt to your
problem that you've got and these guys
didn't know but but we gave them I think
20 thousand dollars to go buy this
this bolt tester and it ended up saving
a shuttle flight by probably probably
six months of effort so again so we will
definitely do that well we're going to
stay I call it staying hungry you just
need to keep looking at all these things
so when you get a little anomaly or a
little problem that's a gift so then you
got to take that gift and expand it as
far as you can to understand what it's
really trying to teach you and don't
just say that's a one-of-a-kind failure
and blow it off because later I
guarantee you they'll come back because
typically when a major failure occurs
you've seen indications of it coming
along the way and you've ignored those
for a variety of reasons and I think you
guys see that probably in your own
testing in your own labs
other words that need attention in the
same views extremely concerned and so so
they get lectures from me it's called my
kids soccer lecture and and in kids
soccer wherever the ball goes the little
pack of kids moves to the ball right so
I tell them that that's not how you win
soccer games right you win soccer games
by being strategically placed across the
field and the ball may be nowhere near
you but you need to be there so when the
ball gets there you're ready so it's the
same thing here okay you guys focus on
the flow control valve this other
broader team you better be positioned
across that soccer field and and be
ready for that next problem that's
coming because I get very concerned that
you get this tunnel vision that you're
working so hard on this one problem
that's all we talk about and we don't
worry about all the other hundred
thousand things on the shuttle that it
could be a problem to us so that's it
that's a very good point well when I was
convinced probably at the second Flight
Readiness review so the first flight
radius review I was not ready yet
because there was still enough
uncertainty but then by the second one I
had enough of an indication that I was
relying on flight history I was using it
smartly that we weren't seeing this all
the time I couldn't believe that we
could couple into this every time and I
thought our dye pen met penetration
measurement was probably good enough to
go fly so I was convinced at that point
I was pretty much ready to go fly but my
team at that point convinced me that I
wasn't ready to go fly so I acquiesced
to the team and we decided to stand down
and it turned out that one of those
three valves we were going to try to fly
did have a crack in it when we looked at
it with the eddy current but it also
surprised us - one of the very low
flight rate valves one of the four
flight valves ouch
actually also had a crack in it so you
really have got to do this this this
inspection so it's the hydrogen assist
that's causing those cracks to deform at
a non-uniform rate so so I was a little
bit ahead of the team I think in terms
of where I was ready to go but the
broader team wasn't there
look at that but it turns out we're
throttling because the load on the
outside of the vehicle it's around
haikyuu or the highest dynamic pressure
on the outside of shuttle we have to
throttle back or the loads get exceeded
where the shuttle attaches to the
external tank so there's really not much
choice there and that's all automated in
software so so those throttle buckets
are going to occur they're based on
winds of the day they're based on what
the atmospheric conditions are so I
can't even predict them and I can't I
can't bucket them out in software so so
they're gonna happen so they're going to
be there and they're gonna couple in and
at random when they occur so so there
was no way to defense against that I'm
trying to not let it affect the way
we're flying you know I I'm supposed to
fly all the remaining shuttle flights
there's nine there's really eight but
we're going to get another one added to
fly an AMS so there'll be nine shuttle
flights we have to get those done by
December 31st 2010 is the schedule but I
don't really let that drive us we're
going to work these things and when
we're ready to go fly we're gonna go fly
so I think you need to be at my words
you need to be schedule aware you know
there's a Soyuz launch after this so if
I missed this first window then I got to
go on the other side of the Soyuz launch
my whole rest of my manifest ripples a
little bit so then I moved from the last
flight being in September to the last
flight being in October that's not a big
deal we'll do the right thing so I think
I'm aware of where the schedule sits but
I'm surely not going to do anything or
push anything that makes makes us fly
when we're not ready to go fly-in and
you could see that in the team I mean
when I sat there and I discussed with
the team you know you asked me when I
was ready to go fly I was definitely
ready to go fly when a team wouldn't let
me go fly they you know I they tape all
these things so someday somebody will
play this back and I have this
politically incorrect moment where I
explain to them all the other risks that
were getting pushed on the space station
side and the assembly flights and all
the other activities on board station
and were dependent upon this flight
occurring and that that even though we
thought we were doing the conservative
thing we
you may have been pushed and risk in
other areas unbeknownst to us now that I
should not say that right and I feel
really bad because I've listened you
know I was in the shuttle program for
both Challenger and for Columbia so
that's tough I mean that's really hard
in our business because I worked with
all the astronauts very closely their
kids went to school with my kids
and and that's a huge failure so I'm not
going to do that knowingly and I'm not
going to push hard but but I wanted them
to know that there were other risks out
there and it wasn't quite as easy as
they wanted to make it so I exposed them
a little bit to my world and I got a lot
of weird looks from him when I did that
because they were not really thinking
about all those other risks that were
getting pushed out and but then I felt
kind of bad about that because I didn't
want to put over pressure on him to
start focusing on schedule so so it's
that kind of as a manager you're kind of
you got to know when to push the team
right and when to pull back from the
team you know there's that performance
curve right and where you want to
operate is you want to operate right at
that peak of the performance curve right
if you're overloaded and you got too
much work you're on that other side and
and bad things happen you just it just
doesn't work if you're on the other side
you push a little bit harder you get
more performance so you as a manager got
to figure out where your team is or
where your project is or are you on that
left side where if I push them a little
bit harder they can work a little bit
harder on weekends and they can do some
extra work and it won't be a degradation
in my project or they right at that peak
and if I push them a little bit harder
then they're overloaded and then the
whole team dynamic falls apart and we
stop so so the manager you've got to
make that kind of value judgment of when
to push and when not to push
it's a gas this kid sure but other times
the the CFD for this particular thing
when it flows through there there are
it's it's like a converging diverging
nozzle it's it's sonic at that minimum
area but then it opens back up and it
actually goes supersonic downstream so
then the question is when this little
piece breaks off right and now the flow
increases how does that dynamically
change and can that accelerate the
particle maybe even 2,000 feet per
second so we ran all these christ
supercomputers CFD runs to look at this
and man is it complicated and man was
there a huge debate so then we finally
said okay we'll take the worst case and
that's what we're gonna fire particles
that because we didn't know what else to
do but but there's definitely a research
area to go look at that i mean it is
very complicated flow and it's not
symmetric you know we can now look at it
because if you think about it you know
it's flowing in the top then it flows
around the valve and then it flows out
so it's not symmetric it actually
vibrates back and forth it is a very
complicated flow regime when you get
there now the other thing that's very
interesting is when they did all this
original shuttle design they had no CFD
so they had no capability to do what
we're able to do now and now I look at
it and and you know I don't have the
time to study it for for a lifetime so
we're trying to determine what is the
right bounding conditions to figure out
the flow particles and it was very very
difficult but we looked at that and we
struggled with that and we had the best
side would say we had some of the best
CFD folks in the country working on this
problem
is there any way to compare the
complexity of the center launch system
versus the space shuttle system and and
then you say the wolf will take each
each collective each collection of
complication I see which is the most
part most reliable would have a
different value than a way to enter an
orbit for the first station assembly is
it worth the risk of to use this thing
versus what we had in the Saturn system
I think that's a very good question the
shuttle is a tremendously capable
vehicle I mean there's no vehicle that
can carry you know this flight carried
up at the solar array that goes on the
outside of Space Station that was a
40-foot long solar array wait about
20,000 pounds
it took the full cargo capability
there's no vehicle that could carry that
including the center so it was truly
unique truly needed this shuttle so
there was no other way that these could
get there so but that's one reason but
because of that the shuttle is
unbelievably complicated right it has a
heat shield on the outside which is not
a good thing it's cantilevered off the
external tank which is not a good thing
I've got all these pyro events that have
to occur when we do separation it has a
hole in the heat shield where the
hydrogen and oxygen umbilical is
attached to the bottom in the orbiter
and they flow through 17 inch pipes up
into the main engines that are attached
in the shuttle through that that's not a
good thing it's got two doors that have
to close after you get to orbit to make
sure the heat shields attack so you're
launching with a failed heat shield to
begin with then you have to close two
doors to get it there that's not
necessarily a good design so it's a very
complicated integrated system and you
saw here I had to I had to look at new
orbiter half I had to look at the 79
foot a pipe on the outside I had to look
at all those systems to make sure that
they could they could work and be used
so that it's very complicated
so the Saturn is much more for a single
vehicle that's where we're heading with
the new areas of Ryan design we're going
to separate crew and cargo so we're
going to fly cargo in a separate vehicle
flight crew in another vehicle and I
think we can cut down on some of those
interactions and some of the
complexities between
so I think we need to be heading to the
system that more matches what our needs
are these flights are needed because
there's no other were difficult than the
shuttle that can fly these remaining
flights all the hardware's uniquely
geared to them we take the risk for
these nine flights and then that's about
the right time to retire the shuttle and
then go onto the new system that's more
geared to what we need to go do what's
interesting is if you look at the new
Russian design which they haven't showed
you yet but you'll see it in about a
year they're they're going back to the
shuttle a little bit they're going to go
to a lifting body and they don't think a
single flight vehicle is the way to go
so the shuttle is the one extreme right
totally recyclable everything's reusable
except for the external tank the Soyuz
nothing is reusable it's a one-shot one
deal Russians looked at that they've won
if they want to try to fly ten times
with a lifting body and they want to
minimize their their braking thrusters
and some other stuff on their vehicle so
they're heading back towards the shuttle
so it's interesting we swung now all the
way to totally expendable the Russians
are coming back towards some recyclable
and then the Chinese they effectively
have copied what the Russians had and
they Chinese engineered it in my terms
they fixed they got all the problem
reports for the Soyuz and they fixed
everything that showed up in a problem
reports they put a new modern avionics
on it but it's basically a Soyuz system
so they the Chinese are trapped back in
the Soyuz Vintage the Russians are going
to be going towards us and we're going
back towards where the Russians are and
and that'll show up on some web
somewhere and then I'll be like in big
trouble but it's
alright that maybe not I don't know we
we don't even know it their docking
system is compatible with the docking
system on station so we have not had any
dialogue with them we've had no
discussions with them so the first thing
again kind of from the technical
standpoint is is are their systems even
compatible with ours
you know they supposedly use the Russian
system but I don't know if they used it
is it truly compatible or not they may
have changed the diameter they may have
changed some of the latching mechanisms
it may not be compatible so the first
question is we got it have somebody kind
of politically tell us we want to go do
this and then if they do then we got to
go back and look at it and you're seeing
some people talk about it but you know I
don't know at this point I look at it as
an engineering problem first of all I
look at compatibility and then we'll
figure out the timetable to go do
whatever we want to go do with a TV HTV
caught something like that what are the
challenges you're facing with thinking
of all these different vehicles having
to be accommodated at station yeah I
think what's really interesting back to
your point everybody thinks the shuttle
is is really tough right well I also in
you know not only do I do space shuttle
and space station I also do expendable
launch vehicles right so I even have
more headaches but but I'm learning that
that there's something about space that
is really at about our engineering
capability so I don't know if you've
watched the LV world but I'm also
scrubbing LV flights all the time for
for you know leaks in this system we
just had the Atlas 5 there oxygen system
just had a massive leak and one of their
oxygen pumps on the second stage they
tore it apart they looked at the inlet
it was full of crud from insulation that
somebody had sprayed in upstream and
it's all got sucked into the inlet
filter so you tend to think our systems
are all easy and they're not there but
if you really do the engineering and you
peel behind the press reports and you
look we're really working
state-of-the-art in a lot of areas and
and I think it's hard even in the
expendable world so that's a challenge
to us because I think people
think it's easy we're working with the
orbital space corporation that they're
going to build a new rocket force is
gonna use Russian engines and a Russian
design tank they're in the process of
qualifying that there's Elon Musk and
SpaceX who's had one successful Falcon
one launch and three failures he likes
to talk about his one success and not
his three failures I look at him as a
package it's good that he's learning he
also has a lot of trouble launched he's
supposed to launch here in five days I
think on April 20th with his first
payload that'll be pretty exciting to
see how that goes so we're following all
that the ATV was a miraculous docking I
mean all that software was done the
first time we came up and docked this
vehicle to station this huge vehicle to
the back we did extensive ground testing
it took us 14 days from launch to dock
and the reason it took 14 days his
orbital mechanics we could be there in
two but we spent the other 12 days
checking systems out we would fly within
a hundred meters we would back out we
would fly within 20 meters we'd back out
we check attitude control systems we
check crew displays to make sure all
that works so then by the time we
finally came in for the dock it was a
fully checked out vehicle so we did
essentially a prote of flight flight on
that flight so we had cargo that we
needed but it wasn't absolutely critical
and then we did essentially the test
program all the way to dock we're going
to do the same thing this September with
a Japanese vehicle it's the HTV it's
going to fly up underneath space station
and stop and then get picked up by the
Canadian or the SSRMS of space station
and robotic system and then then berth
to the bottom of station so that brings
a whole new series of challenge with us
we've been working that program for 15
years so when that thing actually flies
it will have 15 years of hard
engineering sitting behind it before it
goes flies and we'll do the same kind of
probably I think it's a 16 day profile
to come up and do the HTV demo and test
so again yeah it's a tremendous
challenge it's a lot of different
vehicles so now we have to learn a lot
of different systems but again that's
what's kind of neat is an engineers you
get to see how the Japanese solve a
problem how the Russians solve a problem
how the Europeans solve a problem how
the Russians solve a problem it's the
same physical engineering
problem and each one of them takes a
slightly different engineering approach
to it and when I get to cease I get to
see them all and then I get to kind of
internalize now which one might be a
little bit better in this application
and which one might not be so it's a
great program our failure probabilities
about 1 in 77 and the primary driver for
that is micrometeoroid debris damage
on-orbit so again our heat shield is
fully exposed so there's some things
that can occur to our heat shield that
we can't we inspect two days before we
land but we don't inspect any time after
that so in those final two days we could
pick up some damage that's undetectable
or we didn't know about it could be a
heat shield problem and that that's the
predominant risk during during entry and
that's what drives the one in 77 this
problem would have been who knows what
it would have been before but this one
in 450 was this specific problem with
all the techniques that I described so
so I did essentially a distribution
about all the the particles that I fired
down the tubes I did a distribution
about how likely this thing is to break
between 10 degrees and 180 degrees all
those were in there and that's just a
mathematical sum well we assumed we
assumed it was catastrophic we later did
analysis and we determined we could
actually tolerate that leak you know the
leak I showed you in the corner that
little hole we could actually tolerate
that hydrogen leak in the after
compartment so it wouldn't affected tank
pressurization we would have leaked a
little bit and only if that hydrogen
would have combined with oxygen and
drifted over to one of my AP use that
sits at a thousand degrees Fahrenheit
Kuya potential detonation I think that's
very unlikely but to just be worst case
we assumed that that was possible and
was a catastrophic failure so I would be
very careful with our PRA stuff it's
just a math model the absolute values do
not mean
anything that PRA is very good if you're
trying to compare system so if I'm going
to make a systems design change and I'm
using the same math model then I can
look and see which system design gives
me more reliability than another one but
to try to use this PRA and compared to
say Soyuz or compared to HTV or to
compare it to Saturn or other vehicles
you cannot do that it you you you don't
know the models behind them are so
different that it's not it's not
attractive also it's I look at it as a
tool but do not ever use this tool for
any critical decisions other than maybe
looking at two specific designs in the
same system and I have a lot of trouble
with my friends in Washington who don't
really understand statistics explaining
that the other thing that's very
important is you never we always talk
about the mean we should really talk
about the 95 percentile and the five
percentile and we should and you'll see
me you'll see in all my plots and I'm
slowly the shuttle team has never done
this until the past three years then I'm
making them show the fives and 95s and
now we're doing statistical significance
even though the mean is different is it
really statistically different between
the two the other thing we're playing
with this now cani cani contract the
variance in other words can I understand
the problem now so the variance is
smaller than I understand the problem
better that's just as good sometimes as
it is changing the mean and man does
that not sell well in Washington when I
try to explain the lawyers here's mean
here's one Sigma here's 3 Sigma here's
why I'm trying to control the mean and
here's why I'm trying to control the 1
Sigma variation they look like I'm from
some other planet but but that's part of
my job is to convey in English terms
what we're trying to do and you guys
need to think about that as you talk to
folks - well if the commercial cargo
guys come through there's going to be
some pressurize down this will get about
a metric ton maybe 2 metric tons per
year out of the commercial guys so we'll
get some down I'm really dependent upon
the commercial guys coming through so
this is an awkward situation now you
know before we've had always had a NASA
back
and we didn't count on the commercial
sector to develop a rocket or bring
capability up and then what happens is
they run into problems we default to the
NASA solution and we kill a commercial
industry right well this time they
didn't give me enough money to do that
so this time I am 100% dependent upon
those folks and I more than proud to
tell them every time I am dependent upon
them so if they come through we will
have a good research program if they do
not come through it will be a mess
because we'll be very limited and up
massive down mass I need about 40 metric
tons of cargo per year from the
commercial sector so ATV and HTV and
progress can keep my crew on orbit but I
can't do any research and I can do very
limited maintenance to do anything
worthwhile with station I need this
commercial cargo stuff it's supposed to
come first slide in 2010 and in 2011 so
it'll be very important to see that if
they don't come on precisely those dates
that's okay I'm a program manager I got
some margin in the dates they're not
required on absolutely that date but
within a couple years they need to be
there so so the answer to your question
is that the commercial sector comes
about we're there then I've effectively
recertified to the intent if you look at
my external tanks right they look
exactly the same as the tank i fluid
return to flight it's not the same tank
I changed out all the lithium aluminum
up in the dome section back to just
plain old aluminum because it's easier
to manufacture so when I did that I had
to do an entire recertification of the
external tank all the finite element
analysis all the structural analysis all
the breakup analysis and all that so
nobody counts that but I would say in a
sense I've recertified the external tank
when I had some main engine problems I
essentially went back and cleaned
sheeted all the main engine stuff again
so I have done bits and pieces of all
the stuff that I think is needs to keep
this vehicle flying for the remaining
flights so I think I've satisfied the
intent of what the cave was asking me
for in that recertification activity now
I do have some inspection requirements
on the orbiters that they could fly I
think
five years or so many flights and then
we'd take them down we do a major
corrosion inspection some of these
orbiters will be due for a major
corrosion inspection if I try to fly
beyond 2010 we'll have to take those
orbiters out of the fleet do that
corrosion inspection and do that work
and that'll be costly and it's not
effective I also plan on retiring these
vehicles sequentially so when I retire
whatever vehicle first the first thing
I'm going to go do is my hydraulic
actuators they've been in the vehicle
since 1980 and they've never been
removed we're going to go pull those
hydraulic actuators out and we're going
to dissect them and we're gonna go look
in there and see cuz nobody has ever had
a hydraulic actuator installed in an
application for how many ever years of
this 20-some years 28 years so we're
gonna go in and we're gonna actually go
look at that stuff so I'm going to
dismantle one of my orbiters in in to
stay hungry mode that I call it of
looking for problems that haven't shown
up yet to see if there's anything else
out there that we've missed so I'm going
to destructively start evaluating and
testing some of my vehicles that I take
them offline but I don't think I need to
do a full up certification if I do that
kind of investigation did you run into
any major design problems which you
thought needed to be reworked or
something like that and from the testing
that you did to or from the analysis
into how confident would you be in
again the things we kind of discovered
was we have a lot of new tools we didn't
have when we did the original work so we
did the full finite element models of
the tank and we never had those before I
also have a better understanding of the
environment I'm flying in than I did
before
so with a combination a better finite
element and better environment I think I
got a much better design and I did find
some areas of the tank where some of the
pressure lines attached to the outside
of the tank that were less than the
factor of safety we wanted for materials
so we had to beef some areas up when we
did that work so there were some minor
changes but nothing major stuck out is a
big kind of hiccup or a big problem but
the neat thing was to go back with the
new tools and to go look at him and then
pull out the old analysis and then
realize how much we had missed with the
old analysis that we didn't even know
about that was covered in a blanket
factor of safety or was covered in a
blanket assumption you know a
handwritten note that this is okay and
it's got the handwritten calculation
underneath it right I now got a full you
know thousand element finite element
analysis of that individual part and it
looks a lot different so it was a very
instructive situation in terms of
continue to fly I think it's okay to fly
but it goes back to the point back here
we're getting to a point where the need
of the shuttle is not there you know the
uniqueness to carry these things up and
to get the big down mass isn't there and
if I can get to the next generation a
vehicle that has less of an integrated
and complex problem that's a much better
way of going so I don't think from a
safety standpoint I'm worried but from a
practical standpoint we need to retire
the shuttle when it's done these complex
missions and then get that next
generation of vehicle that's going to
have it will have problems I guarantee
it will have problems it will have
problems especially its startup you know
the typical bathtub curve lives you find
a lot of problems in a very new system
you find a lot of problems in a very old
system in the middle you're in the sweet
spot so when it the new systems start
flying they'll find lots of problems but
but that's okay you're still you know
working those out working the bugs out
but that system because the heat shields
protected it has an abort system on top
it will be inherently more safe than
than what the shuttle is just by its
basic design
I think when Columbia broke up over
Texas one of the astronauts lost I was
an Israeli is there any are we holding a
slot open for them and if they were
doing that we would be put in Iran in in
with them so that something would kick
off or President Obama's talks with Iran
I don't know and that's probably for
some alter ego other than me so I some
policy person could talk to you about
that the Russians are very good at
flying anybody and everybody so if
you've got a if if you got a thirty so
that's where I'm going if you have a
thirty five million dollar spare change
to fly that's the new price you can be a
tourist onboard Space Station so so what
I should have done in my career I
shouldn't went to work for NASA I should
have went to some entrepreneurial
company made thirty five million dollars
and that could be an astronaut so I so I
ruined my career by going to work for
NASA so so no I'm not supposed to say
that so you're supposed to continue to
ruin your careers by working for NASA
and working for the low government stuff
and don't make that money because then
all you can do is go fly in space as a
tourist anything else yeah maybe one
more the science Mission Directorate
does that they do they have a whole
bunch of committees that go look at what
scientific investigations need to be
done out there and and I just focus
really on the human spaceflight side of
things except for I provide the launch
vehicles for the scientific missions but
but that's all so anyway hopefully you
learned something today we internal the
NASA we looked at at our age profile and
and we're aging and so is the aerospace
industry and in general so we think we
need to bring in some more new hires so
we're going to try to make a concert
concentrated effort to bring in some
fresh outs in there next next series of
hiring so we think some hiring windows
are open it up so from our standpoint we
want to bring some some new ideas some
new fresh blood in it
it wasn't happening because you know if
you've got a crunch project like the new
Orion and airy stuff what typically
happened is the program manager will go
pick somebody from industries familiar
with this fairly seasoned and bring them
in so we're now going to force some
mixture of some new fresh outs to come
in because we think we need to
reinvigorate new ways of doing business
and new tools and new processes in our
system so so you're going to see kind of
a push for us to start start looking at
that so so I think things are this is a
very good time in spaceflight in a sense
it's it's sad in a way that the shuttle
is retiring but I think the shuttle is
retiring but just because we can't
afford to do shuttle and any other thing
and and we really would need to do some
probably some kind of upgrades to the
shuttle to some extent maybe some kind
of escapes that real escape system or
something if we continue to fly it so
the shuttles gotta wind down but the in
the station is there the station is a
you truly unique research facility we're
about done assembling so then how can we
use it and we talked about using it for
medical and biological and and know
those things but we also have to think
about it as an engineering test bed you
know I've got pumps up there that have
been running for multiple years I've got
ammonia systems that have been operating
well I've got heat exchangers they're
doing good I got cuties that I would
never fly in any vehicle again if I ever
had a chance so we're never gonna fly
those but but we've learned all this
stuff and the idea is now how can I pass
that on to the next generation or can we
do some actual testing of these systems
to see do they make sense because we're
going the same kind of systems on the
moon we're gonna have some kind of
cooling system some kind of power
generation system so can we test some of
those systems and components on Space
Station can we test software on Space
Station can we use time liner to go
control simple functions that are
controlled in code or they're done by
crews on the ground can we do you know I
want to do a day without commands -
Space Station typically today we send a
thousand commands to Space Station today
so I've challenged a team when you're
going to Mars and and you're there
you're not gonna be able to send command
so I want to give you a challenge you're
going to send no commands for one day
after they achieve that they don't know
this they're going to get a decree - no
commands for a week and then after they
achieve that they're going to get no
commands for a month
so you can't tell them that but they'll
see it on the web if they watch
hopefully they're busy doing software
design and not watch
so but but the idea is to push and how
can we demonstrate stuff that might be
appropriate you know I told the crews
that I was going to take away all their
windows so they couldn't look at the
earth so they could simulate the journey
to Mars for six months and then we would
return them the crews told me that there
was no way they would ever do that if
they were going to Mars they would do
without the view of the earth but if
they're this close to the earth and
they're spending six months in space
they're looking out the window and and
they were not going to participate in
that but but you could help me think of
what kind of things can we do with Space
Station that demonstrates its use in
exploration because it's a tremendous
research facility so again back what the
future is shuttles ramp and down station
is a great research facility how do we
use it
I'm invigorating a new commercial
spaceflight industry which is exciting
they're doing things a different way the
NASA does they're not doing the
traditional way they're doing more
entrepreneurial engineering which is a
great way of doing business you know
I've got the new vehicles being designed
we haven't designed new vehicles for a
long time the intent is to use the Ares
vehicles not only for the moon but also
for Mars so they have that future design
capability in there so this is a great
time to come out and get involved in
this industry and do things so I think
again the hiring in aerospace is always
up and down it's a pretty dynamic field
I went into aerospace because I thought
I would get out of school and I wouldn't
be able to go to work anywhere and I
would use that as an excuse to tour the
world for a year it didn't work out well
I got out of school and it was on the
peak hiring and so then I went right to
work and that was the beginning of the
end so I have not yet toured the world
but but but again you just have to put
up with that in aerospace but I think
it's a great profession I don't think
there's any better team than I have in
shuttle station expendable launch
vehicles and space communications I mean
they understand the mission they
understand what has to be done they're
tremendously disciplined they're
inventive as I saw here you know I
didn't tell him to go buy a you know
bolt tester they went out on their own
they had no idea it was going to work
but they thought heck it's worth a try
they didn't even know if it would you
even be worthwhile they didn't even
think we needed to do it but they did it
anyway so so I mean what a great work
environment to have folks that are that
dedicated that creative that and that
know they have to work together as a
team it's almost like being in college
again being on
you know and a project team working for
that that final a final project to get
it done except it's it's a little more
intense and it lasts longer than a
semester all right well thanks
[Applause]